اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم مظاهرات متواصله لاهالي
الاسر في تل ابيب والقدس وحيفا ليبرمان
يطالب بتشكيل حكومه اسرائيليه جديده ويتهم
الحكومه الحاليه بالعجز ويدي عت احرنوت
تكشف ان مقربين من بايدن يعتقدون ان
نتنياهو يطيل امد الحرب لاسباب سياسيه
وشخصيه وتجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في
رابط بالتعليق الاول كوريا الجنوبيه تقول
ان جارتها الشماليه اطلقت صاروخا بالستيا
باتجاه بحر اليابان بعد ايام على اجرائها
تدريبات بالذخيره الحيه قرب الحدود
البحريه للبلدين من جانبه ذكر خفر السواحل
الياباني ان مقذوفا يعتقد انه الصاروخ
الكوري الشمالي سقط بالفعل
هناك الدنماركيون يتوافدون الى كوبنهاجن
لمشاهده الملكه مارجريت ثانيه اطول ملوك
الدنمارك حكما وهي تسلم العرش لابنها
البكر فريدريك وذلك بعد قرارها المفاجئ
عشيه راس السنه بالتنازل عن العرش بعد 52
عاما شركه بيتا فولت الصينيه تكشف عن
تطوير بطاريه نوويه بحجم عمله معدنيه لا
تحتاج الى الشحن لمده 50 عاما الشركه قالت
ان هذه البطاريه امنه ولا تحتوي على
اشعاعات وستدخل في انتاج الهواتف
والطائرات المسيره الى
اللقاء